a couple of years ago I believed that
you should never hit a woman I thought
that hitting a woman was wrong and that
really what would a woman need to do do
deserve to be hit I was una aware of
just how violent women are where I grew
up it was not normal to have women hit
men that wasn't something I really saw
ever the more I got into media the more
I had conversations with men and women
the more I realized that behind closed
doors women absolutely beat the out
of their husband I couldn't believe how
many men had been hit by women and so I
started to see the types of punches that
these women would throw and I thought to
myself if you want to hit like a man
then expect to get hit like a man I have
zero sympathy